being an empath I believe is somewhat of
a learned mechanism that has been
birthed because of trying to get your
own needs met so part of being an empath
is tuning to other people into what
they're feeling because then it's like
if I can make you happy or if I can
please you or let the tension go away
and you feel good then I can feel good
so it's a mechanism that was learned as
a kid to ease tension to then get other
people to feel a certain way so then I
could say oh now I can feel safe and the
problem with that though is that then
when you tune to other people that often
uh what ends up happening is you lose
your sense of self you lose what I call
your frame your sense of frame and
feeling safe in your own frame and being
able to set boundaries with other people
being able to feel and live according to
your own values because as a people
pleaser or an empath you tune to other
people and your values become their
values whatever they value like I value
that too